privileged to be here I know there was
another talk scheduled so hopefully
nobody here is expecting to have some
energy efficiency that'll be a good talk
unfortunately the individual couldn't
make it to PI data that happens
occasionally so I get to jump in and I'm
thrilled because I love to talk about
number it's sort of one of two topics
I've been talking about over the past
several years since we're kind of
stepping down from active involvement
with the numpy community and just sort
of playing a a grandfather role I
suppose it's great to see all the people
here I'm glad but I know there's other
two interesting talks happening I'm
super excited to talk about number Idol
I actually don't think number gets
enough I still hear people who haven't
heard of it let's see in this room
anybody not using number I raise your
hand if you're not using number yeah
perfect exactly see now that's fine I
mean number isn't yet in everybody's DNA
but it it really could be with just a
few tweaks it really is amazing
currently it can be used basically
anytime you have analytics code that's a
Rea like with scalars so in typical
numpy situations number will really help
you write high level code anytime you're
trying to reach to C or Fortran you
often don't have to and you can just go
keep Python code and put a JIT decorate
around it or a vectorized decorator
around it depending how your code is
organized and get speed ups very very
quickly those who have done it have sort
of the bit has been very grateful for
it's working now it there's still some
caveats still some things it's not going
to be you know Python gets us a little
lazy sometimes nightly it's the wrong
word it spoils us right Python is
spoiling us because it's so beautiful
and it can fit our brain and we can just
write code and it sort of rolls off our
minds into the into the computer and
number isn't quite like that all the
time it's not quite possible to just
roll off your mind advanced analytics
code and have it be as fast as you want
and still as expressive and clear as
Python so but some change some things
are getting better but a lot of things
do get better when you go to compile
code so there is a space of Kampai thunk
compilation and it's important to talk
about that space at least a little bit
so you understand number
and everything to all people number sort
of is an area of this space it's just in
time a little bit of ahead of time
that's sort of in the in the
experimental stages but certainly on the
roadmap is to for number to be able to
ahead of time compile pre-compile
modules extension modules but still it's
relying on the C Python Lib Python
runtime sort of not going beyond that
now number actually has a little bit of
a segue tiny tiny segue experimental
mode into replacing its replaces the
wrong word but being able to create a
shared module doesn't rely on the Python
and could be linked by something else
but that's sort of a different space so
it is not trying to be a just-in-time
compiler that replaces all of your
Python code and I actually something
like PI Jian pigeon hi Jin pigeon pigeon
which was shown by Dino yesterday if you
didn't see that please look at the video
it's maybe not the whole video if you're
not in the compiler theory but at least
the front in the back it's a really cool
proposition that I think I think homes
holds some promise in helping bring JIT
technology to more of your simple and
Python code number most of the time is
trying to compile your code and it's
also not necessarily a hot at racing jet
a JIT that tries to determine when
you're calling it and then compile that
which is it sees is being called a lot
of times it actually is a it's a it's a
intentional JIT it's a JIT you say yeah
please get this code and then it will do
that on import time or on call time
depend on how you you call it so it's
it's a tool to be used to make your code
faster especially and with a focus on
array oriented table oriented code which
is very common analytics world there's
some other action interesting tools out
there that are doing similar things
Python scythe on pythons sort of a uses
comments and then creates an extension
module that you compile ahead of time
rather interesting it completely it uses
the C compiler in the end it translates
Python code to a c code that you then
compile the c compiler numba uses of
LLVM technology currently you know i
like to show this slide because many
people aren't you know to them
compilers or something that somebody
else does the compilers are really a
fairly straightforward concept you are
parsing something written in ASCII or
Unicode to every compiler I've seen has
some internal intermedia representation
they use some internal even if it's a
set of data structures in memory and not
formally specified but there's something
internally they're using and then that
then the compiler can basically focus on
a parsing front-end that produces this
intimate representation and usually
there's sort of several steps of
translation in that intermediate
representation to go make improvements
make optimizations and then it comes the
backend code generation
so with numba we're relying heavily on
another project called lov m to do that
intermediate code generation to back end
to x86 arm PTX is actually the code it's
the bytecode that Nvidia uses on their
GPUs actually so with LLVM and number we
actually get GPU calculations of GPU
backends for free sort of so that's one
of the reasons we're choosing the VM is
to sort of try to unify and help unify
CPU and GPU codes but number basically
just takes Python and it doesn't even do
any parsing right Python does all the
parsing for us as well so it's really
kind of it's the easiest compiler you
could think of it's just going from
Python bytecode to LLVM I are now even
that requires a bit of there's a lot of
gotchas and questions and thoughts
around that and interesting problems in
that space as well but we're relying
heavily on the work of a lot of people
so it's exciting that's why we can make
progress but it also gives us a lot of
room to do some interesting things very
simple example not something you would
really do in practice but you could
basically decorate a simple function
written in Python this one just goes
over a bunch of integers and calculates
ratios and you could calculate that in
Python do that in Python it's a for loop
you wouldn't think that that wouldn't
typically do it that way
you'd rather slow but with the jet it
translates that to low-level machine
code and gets very very fast results
what you see is a representation of LVM
intermediate representation it's it's
semi readable I mean you have to once
you get your adjust your eyes and get
the right glasses and kind of what to
put a filter on your brain then you can
kind of walk through okay I get what's
happening I only
some constructions and branching and
some comparisons and it turns out that's
enough to produce machine code on a
large variety of machines
that's what number does now how does
number work here's kind of the slide
that goes into more detail about what
number does to go from Python byte code
to LLVM ir and then ultimate in code so
when you see a function at JIT and
that's the recommended interface
basically there's two functions use out
a number JIT and then we'll see later
vectorize and they're not presently you
don't have to call either one of them
with arguments you can call it arguments
you'll see some examples of that later
on but the recommended approach is not
to call it with arguments so it doesn't
if when you don't call it with arguments
in the doesn't bytecode analysis and
constructs an intermediate
representation a number I are this
basically an intermediate often takes
the number can use to then inject type
information that acquires once the
function gets called so when you define
the function with JIT it actually
returns this intermediate delayed
function evaluation it's kind of a it
replaces the function with a object that
when it gets called will evaluate the
function arguments passed in now you
know the types the function argument
passed in when you don't have any
functions any arguments passed in then
note that a and B they could be anything
integers floats raised in or what it is
and so therefore the code that gets
generated could be quite different it's
so like templating it's very very
similar to template e in fact it's so
you create this sort of unintentional
when you call it now it has type
information and then it uses type
inference the num number I R has some uh
Nana Tate 'add information that hey I
don't know what the types of these
things are the type inference takes the
types of the inputs all the functions
are calling tries to determine all the
types of the intermediate variables
inside the function as well as the
output return types that is not always
possible as you can imagine Python is
very very dynamic people call all kinds
of funny modules functions that nobody
understood the number certainly doesn't
understand and so if it doesn't know
what is returned it just sticks a
generic PI object it knows about the
product type and just sticks generic PI
object and effectively when you can't do
type inference
everything then you've got you're really
back to the Python C API or the Python
runtime just doing function calls on
objects exactly like the runtime works
with Python so you won't get any speed
up if it can't do type inference
that's essentially and any any people
that struggle with numpy it none but not
giving them speed-up it's because the
type inference didn't succeed and why
didn't the type of inference succeed
likely because you called some function
it doesn't understand or some operation
potentially didn't understand and we've
been sort of working pretty hard and the
number team to make number understand
math functions although you know the
scalar working in syntax and a lot a lot
of the numpy api so if you even use
numpy you can now use numpy inside a
number function and it won't call numpy
it'll actually just generate code for
you that does the same thing as numpy
basically understanding the numpy code
so it makes a sort of a nice tool for a
the numpy user in the numpy stack so
after type inference then it rewrites
the number I are inserting type
information and then it takes that
information lowers it to a closer to LV
Mir where some optimizations occur and
then finally it ejects that I are I
showed you that complicated LV Mir and
at that point LLVM takes over calls the
JIT of LLVM which takes that ir and
produces machine code that machine code
is then executed and there's potential
for some caching along the way that so
you don't have to once you call it with
a certain number of types it caches that
machine code result and doesn't
recompile every time you call it until
you exit python and enter python back
again that caching is currently is not
persistent it's only in memory so you
you pay the cost of compilation once
every time you call the function so the
damage it is it's a function level JIT
it's not going to try to inspect your
code there is one area where it does
something a little bit magic but mostly
mostly it's just going to inspect your
code and compiled machine code what it
can now it has to generate actually two
functions when you have the JIT
decorator around a function think of
what's happening there has to be a
Python entry point to that function
there has to be some Python object that
is an entry point
the machine code so basically two things
are generated one is the Python object
that it calls and the other is the
machine code that it represents that
function so when you call the function
when it's fully type that the full with
full type inference you have those two
there's two mental things those two
concepts floating around now most of the
time you have to think about illness but
if when you do is when you're really
trying to kind of get to the hard maybe
something doesn't go right you're trying
to figure it out then you have to have a
little bit of a mental model that is
accurate that is relatively consistent
so what is number support currently the
number teams working really hard and
incidentally number was a project I got
to spend a little bit of time on in 2012
and all the code I wrote at that point
has since been rewritten about three
times and by a very strong team that is
actually consistent of about four or
five people so everything I'm talking
about is is done by them it's a
fantastic group we're always looking for
open source contributors it's a fully
open source project and anybody
interested in getting involved with this
team is welcome to join
so number supports Windows OS 10 and
Linux and that means we're compiling LVM
on all those machines and and making it
available so that each of those it's 32
and 64-bit x86 CPUs and NVIDIA GPUs
there's you know preliminaries there's
on the roadmap support for arm and
support for AMD GP CPUs and the CPU GPU
combinations but that's not yet in
released versions does support Python
two and three we work pretty hard to
make sure that the code is the same
across those two installations and then
numpy versions it does require a numpy
version 1.6 through 1.9 one a lot of
value a lot of people get out of a
number especially Windows users who have
a hard time not having to C plus C or
C++ compiler is it does not require one
so you install numba and you basically
have the equivalent of a compiler
without having to go and install one so
you get the ability to write machine
code just with Python syntax and the
number runtime and it does not replace
the Python interpreter you'd still need
the Python interpreter you still need
numpy
numpy yet either you still need numpy so
oh and then the cap the other flipside
of that is all of your existing Python
libraries still work and are still
available you don't have to switch off
from doing that you can just insert
number into your workflow and then see
if it helps you number you'll often hear
us talk about two different modes and
I'm I got close to describing those
modes when I explained that the type
inference if it doesn't know what it is
will keep object mode it'll keep an
object on those types anytime you have a
function you've jetted where the type
inference did not know what it was or
infer that it's an object your know
what's called object mode when you're a
Python object naturally we can't get rid
of the Python runtime we rely on it to
do the operations so it's called object
mode and effectively you're not going to
get significant and performance
improvements you might get a few
percentage points because you've gotten
rid of the loop the eval loop the switch
statement in Python but a lot of times
no that's not true and you occasionally
might even get a little bit slower so
what we're going for is number is to try
to get you to know Python mode and that
will happen automatically if it can
there is something called no python mode
where you can it doesn't change anything
all it doesn't change what numbers
trying to do all it does is change what
number tells you it says no if you ask
for no python mode then it says give me
an error if you can't do it don't just
go to this other object mode because
there's a to use cases as some people
want to add the JIT and then have it
keep working even if it it didn't get
faster they don't want to something
other code to break other people they're
trying to hotspot analysis really trying
to develop they want to know if it's not
working if they can fix it so you have
those Bhosle basically those two
concepts those two modes know Python
mode what you get is machine code you
get out bits you get out binary strings
that operate at the speed or controlling
the machine you're no longer relying on
live Python you're no longer relying on
anything therefore you're not giving you
the benefits of that dynamic live Python
either but you're able to go as fast you
sleep within 25% of the speed of C or
Fortran so how do you use numba numba
currently it would be awesome if you
sort of have this number command line
sort of number a lot of people ask for
this number
give my Python script and it all just
magically goes fast yeah be cool right
the challenge is that like I said before
Python is very dynamic and it's
something clear what you've done and you
probably have taken advantage of that
throughout your code using dictionaries
and sets and lists and all kinds of cool
features that make your code expressive
and numbers not going to be able to do
anything with all of that there's a
whole list of features of Python that
are not supported by a number and what's
really a subset of Python that can be
optimized so to use number it's really
about creating a realistic benchmark the
test the unit tests are typically not
the right benchmark it typically don't
aren't aren't you're not going to get
the speed-up you're looking for because
you're it's a different purpose so
having some kind of benchmark test cases
run a profiler on those benchmarks and
then identify those hotspots now I know
from experience and you know numbers
been around since early 2012 but not
really usable since until early 2013 and
then you know it's gone through a couple
of changes in 2013 after since 2014 has
been pretty stable the same code base
the same it's been moving forward more
iteratively more slowly
a lot of backward compatibility since
January 2014 and since that time we've
used it in lots of projects we've used
it and done exactly this and a lot and
really helped a lot of people go from
code that's running slow to getting to
10 even 100 500 X speed ups in their
code bases just in using this process
basically so with number you can really
get a long way and you can give me like
thousand X speed ups if you start taking
advantage of the GPU which is a little
harder still not quite as easy as taking
advantage of the CPU at this point so
it's not by the hot spots that could
potentially be compiled with some maybe
no refactoring but usually there's a
little bit of factoring required and
then use JIT and vectorize in order to
get those critical functions to be
machine code and then rerun the
benchmark see if there's a reformist
improvement so we're going to talk about
some of the number of features here and
kind of give a whirlwind tool of
features this the text here is
inaccurate a fast presentation put
together last night so the basics of
number are just using add JIT on a
function here's a simple example
that asically extracts out is Nan's
so Nan's from an LM from an array it
takes an array and now I'm illustrating
a couple of things here number now has
as of 0.20 release memory allocator so
you can actually allocate memory in know
Python mode outside of and there's
actually a little reference counting
mechanism that's used intrinsic atomic
lock atomic instructions on provided by
many processors to actually manage that
and connect with the Python memory
manager when it goes back to Python so
it gives you the ability to create
arrays inside of your new python mode
which is very very nice and lots of
features fall out of that actually basic
functionality and in the future
including JIT classes will come out of
that too so here I'm creating a new
array inside my know Python mode
function and then notice how I can loop
through the array using natural Python
syntax a disco for element index like in
acts like an iterator but underneath the
covers a generates machine code to do
that in a way and to iterate the pointer
through the array of elements and then I
do a check to see if it's an an and if
it isn't then replace the out index sort
of grab all the functions that are not
man into a new array so that's that's
what out does that's what this little
function does and it's similar you can
get these same effect in numpy by
basically doing masking the selection on
a regular array so basically I'm
implementing that masking selection in a
regular array with just a function I've
compiled with with number and you can
see that in this particular case I'm
getting somewhere to 0.5 X speed-up on
the result so and that's that's usually
pretty typical we see on your num pies
off you know it's it's fast but it oh
it's not always optimal there's sort of
it's a general code base and so it
doesn't always it's not always
particularly for your specific problem
you can get roughly somewhere between
1.8 and even up to 10x speedups
by writing little snippets of code even
over the num num pi code base so that's
why again the hot the performance
optimization is really critical because
you don't want to go be optimizing all
these sections of code in your overall
workflow that are
getting called that much you might be
fun might be enjoyable kind of a nice
pastime perhaps better than playing
minesweeper but not gonna necessarily
get you a faster overall codebase
so so that's a it's it's very simple to
use now I don't have to say no Python
equals true I could have just said add
JIT the only reason to say no Python
equals true is if I want the compiler at
function declaration time to tell me hey
I couldn't excuse me it have to be a
function call time because I haven't
specified any types so at function call
time when I provide some types it'll
tell me I don't know how to infer the
rest of the types in here so I can't go
to a new object mode sorry it'll raise
an error but and sometimes that's
helpful and sometimes it's not and so
that's what that flag does is if you
want to be told when you call it that it
can't do it then put the note python
equals true if you don't then don't do
that it requests in the back that's a
great question yeah the question is you
sees the timing and you know it's the
best of three it's multiple loops so
he's asking what how much times it take
the first time you call it because of
course what happens the first time you
call it with new types it's going to
compile it and the answer is somewhere
between micro hundred microseconds to
ten milliseconds but obviously the more
complicated the code that's being
compiled the longer that can get and if
you know more optimizations are done the
longer that can get as well there is
some LLVM is not known to be a fast
compiler it's sort of been optimized to
be a static compiler with with clang and
other front ends Julie uses it well so
there is some pressure trying to make it
faster and there are improvements being
made in that direction but historically
it's not the fastest JIT out there so
but in the use cases we've our our
applying number which is sort of large
our computational analytics approaches
typically it sits well below the run
time of that function so even the first
time you call it it's gonna be within
ten percent or less of the overall
function result time but it can make a
difference and so it is important
understand the first time you call it it
will have that compilation time and we
are looking at ways as that becomes a
problem you can then start caching
things generating shared object codes
and
layers to speed that up but so far that
hasn't been done in the project itself
yes not a question yeah that's a great
he's asking about keyword arguments
default values keyword arguments and
what is it what does it do in that case
they sort of pre generate perhaps a yeah
that's a fantastic question and I do not
have an answer for you I know that it's
possible that actually keyword arguments
are still not supported right and maybe
that you can't do that actually however
I need to check that because I know that
was on the enhancement list and
something that's been of interest for a
while
so I have to get back with you I don't
know for sure exactly what what the
status of that is it may be the let's
say for now that they don't the keyword
arguments don't work and if they do then
you'd have to understand there'll be
some technical details around how that's
implemented so I guess the annotations
and I could have provided earlier but
I'm really excited about the allocation
earlier you basically could could not
allocate a raise and in number you would
basically have to pass in any array you
wanted to fill in and now you can and so
you can have this it opens up a lot of
doors that be able to sort of doing that
array allocation in the reference
counting and the memory management
necessary to handle that array
allocation it's actually a pretty big
deal we're pretty excited about what
that's going to imply in the coming
months so one thing about using this JIT
is you can then call other jittered
functions inside your functions [ __ ]
and when you do that it will not go
through Python it'll you're just making
a machine phone function that then
another machine code function is calling
and in fact LLVM will I even do in
lining of that function if the function
is is simple enough so here's an example
where the clamp function which is a
simple if statement if statement check
that gets in lined into the calling
angle in the angle between function when
it gets called so because of that that
inlining and that the autumn is
of LLVM will often give you speed up so
if you compare this code is JIT it and
it looks like numpy code right you're
calling numpy Ark Coast and all those
things
but it's not actually calling them pi
when it's in no python mode it actually
is doing the work that numpy would have
done but in a different using a compiled
code
it's about 10x faster in this particular
case but you know one of these functions
doesn't get in line because this little
more complicated the other one does now
one thing I love about number you have a
question in the back yeah
there's basically some there's some
environment variable as you can set that
basically give you more information
about outputs and you can also get the
LVM produced by the function and even
the machine code produced by the
function so there's straightforward
interfaces to taking the function that's
been calling getting the LLVM out of it
it uses so that that's how you would
kind of inspect and look and see and
notice there may be other ways but
that's another's that way the question
was is there a way to get to know that
something's been in lined or not thank
you
so you funks how many don't know what a
you func is we'll see if you're brave
enough to admit awesome you guys are
awesome people it's always good so a you
func is called a universal function it's
a it's the basic mapping function in
numpy but it's kind of magical because
there's a lot of work done to do a few
things one is type couldn't work type
coercion so I can have an integer and a
float together come into you funk and
numpy will pick will coerce them to a
common type that it then can find a
low-level routine that works for it so
there's all this machinery around the
you func object in Python it's actually
written in C but it's a Python interface
that lets you attach low-level group
routines that iterate there do very
simple things it just element by element
iteration doing some function like a
sign or an ad or or a divide or you'll
see later even fancy special functions
but it does things with the arguments
the type coercion it does
rod casting broadcasting means I can put
a scaler with an array and it'll take
that scaler an array and broadcast the
scaler across the array eggs they can
array in a matrix and it'll convert the
array to a matrix with the right
elements so I can combine those two
element all that's done for you with you
folks so I always wanted one of the
first things I was doing when I was
starting the sci-fi project I just
wanted more special functions I wanted
lots of functions for you as you funks
and they were kind of hard to build you
had to do it and see you had to
construct these little functions I
always wanted to say here's a Python
function let's make that the kernel in a
you thunk and it turned out had to write
a compiler to do that so it wasn't
available there is a vectorized function
in numpy there's an umpire vectorize but
it isn't what you what I wanted it's
a-ok at every element here I'm gonna
have an object mode and I'm gonna go
back into the Python runtime and call
the function and put that back at numpy
and I can kind of be a drag when you've
got you know a billion elements in your
array and you're going back into Python
mode and doing something every time with
number vectorize we can actually do this
we can build the kernel that is called
by the numpy by the you thunk machinery
so all that machinery just starts up
front and then hands it over to this
precompiled function and off I go
so you can kind of go be crazy with
yourself and figure out all kinds of
ways if you have a mapping if you have
some way to think about here's my array
or here's my data and I just want to do
some mapping of every element of that
array as comp K is that math you might
be and as many other arguments that
might need you can build that and then
you can apply it to a large data set
that's what you that's what you funks
are did the kernels they get applied to
a large data set so ad is the simple one
I add as a you func and it can apply it
to two arrays and element by element
it'll do that addition here is the Elif
element calculation it actually was
motivated by hearthstone I'd never heard
of that game actually anybody here
played hearthstone okay apparently this
is some stand Seibert lead developer on
numba and he was basically wondering why
it kept losing and so he was trying to
just Monte Carlo simulate kind of the
process of and I basically this game is
you have a win probability number of max
wins number of Max losses and I go
through and generate a random number
it exits as soon as you've basically had
the max number of wins or the max number
of losses and that returns how many wins
right so you're basically trying to
figure out what's the likelihood of this
happening you know interesting
interesting function to call it shows
that there's a loop here in your inner
loop of every element and there's also
random number generation using n pi
numpy random dot R and I should caveat
here you can use n P random dot R and in
a know Python context it generates
machine code for doing a random number
generation but it's not thread safe yet
so and vectorized does implicitly
if it's not object mode numpy will
release the gill it will release the
global interpreter lock and call this in
with so if you call this multiple
threads you might end up with a
challenge or might not might work just
fine but in fact you might have a
problem because it's not guaranteed to
be thread safe so but it's it's fairly
straightforward code and then you can
apply it if you look at that sim input n
P tile all it's doing is generating this
hundred points from 0 and 1 and then
replicating that 5,000 times you end up
with a 5,000 by 100 matrix array and you
can then calculate on that array this
game wins function on every element of
that array broadcasted against 12 and 3
so 12 is a number of wins 3 number of
losses and you're inserting this sort of
wind probability function hey you could
just do this with one this is just
illustrating you could do a bigger job
and not it doesn't take very long 50
milliseconds for that kind of simulation
and you could generate that win
probability curve and see that oh I
could see what I don't do so well I have
to my win probably has to be really
really high before I hit sort of bias
down down pretty low expected number of
wins before the game ends and very
pretty unlikely that I'll actually have
12 wins or than max number so you funks
this to me was a big deal this is sort
of like a one of those moments in in
your life when you sort of have a wish
and desire for many many years and it
comes to pass right after a lot of work
and a lot of help and a lot of other
people you know LLVM a lot of work had
to come to become to come to play
but what it definitely illustrates so
you know a lot of times I think that
motivated me when I
the sci-fi project in 1999 early on and
special was one of the first things I
wrote was I just wanted more stuff
available to Python user I wanted Python
users to be able to do optimization
integration special functions just
wanted them to have all the capability
that he might get in something like
MATLAB ride Yale or PV waver in a number
of these applications so I was very
motivated I was also very young had
didn't didn't care about money
my wife was patient with me and hint
hint and our kids were young so we
didn't have to worry about some of the
things we have to worry about now but I
spent a lot of time just trying to push
this if I had had a number if number had
existed Syfy would be completely
different it'd be completely different
it just would just be completely
different I mean because we could do all
of this almost I mean use a lot a lot of
things just in Python itself and the
things we would need is library form
could just be linked to and I guarantee
everybody would be happier the pie pie
people will be happier the Python people
the offer you would be happier things to
be faster there'd be more things if he
spread it spread safe so I say that
because I think numbers a big deal and I
see that with all the history of all the
effort that I put in a numpy and sci-fi
that I think numba provides us a
framework an opportunity to create
things that go bigger and broader and go
beyond what we have currently in the PI
data stack so I'm very excited about it
it's why we why invest for most resource
so many resources in it I think it has a
lot of a lot of potential so I'm just
illustrating a case study of translating
something from Syfy using numba and
showing the result so here is the Bessel
function I just went to the C code that
was wrapped with SCI PI and I translated
that C code to Python code does the same
algorithm the C fees is doing and it's
basically this pate approximation if you
know what that is in order of a common
function it's got these polynomials you
have two constants you have to insert
and then some polynomial evaluation code
so that's the code I just pull up from C
fees wrote on Python fairly readable you
can even go in there and start arguing
about well I think it ought to be this
length or I think we got to put a
different approximation here I think we
should change this or this a lot more
collaborative a lot more ability for a
lot more people to kind of insert
themselves ago maybe we should fix this
and make it better that's one of the
advantages of
as it brings more people together it
doesn't sort of separate the sacred
algorithm writers from the people that
know what they're you know what
understand maybe the math so now you
don't actually need that type inference
anymore
previously in vectorize you had to it
only you had to give it what types to
generate it for but vectorize now will
there's there's a shim that'll let it'll
do that dynamic compilation on-the-fly
and addition and insert low-level
routines for you so you don't need those
any of those decorators anymore you say
objet and add vectorize and the result
is this vectorized Bessel function that
turns out to be the same speed roughly a
little bit faster in this case but
probably the same speed as the SyFy j0
function so I think that's cool I think
basically so I say all the code
Sify be much different as I said existed
I'd have spent more of my time writing
Python and less my time linking Fortran
so and I would have been happier and we
all would've been happier but now and
you know it could've been you know
moving this to the assist to the GPU we
could have been doing a lot of things so
the words starting to get out and we had
a recent number million list where
somebody else was starting to basically
they got 2x speed-up by taking their
scythe on code that they'd written it
was a spatial hierarchy function inside
of sci-fi and they just took the code
and removed all the type annotations
made up more looking like Python and
then just put JIT around things they
didn't have to change make a few minor
change the code he said it's not perfect
number doesn't just take everything but
he was really pleased there was only a
few minor changes slight differences in
the way he approached it and then it was
2x faster the result so what that means
to me as soon as the numbers ahead of
time compilation where you can actually
use number to generate a shared object
you can then shift to somebody else as
soon as that is moves beyond
experimental stage you can legitimately
use number to create a library which
then doesn't require num but for the
person you're giving it to maybe it
might require a number one time right
that's it's a I'm not going to claim
that it might not but will basically
require a smaller install so some pie
knife I would look very different both
sci-fi and numpy actually will look a
lot different
so number is number is actually getting
some more pythonic things actually it's
uh it's growing one of the complaints is
that it looks a lot like Fortran it does
you should have to write your code like
numpy people would or Fortran people
would and there you know some of the
same people so they're happy but it's uh
you know you kind of like you missed
some of your high-level simple things
and those are slowly being added
generators are now there and number so
number can generate you can basically
create a generator function and then you
it's faster than just doing it in Python
itself so here's just a simple example
of using a generator to you basically
make a an iterator but it's all in
Python it's at two minutes thank you so
releasing the Gil a lot of people fret
about the Gil and Python and for some
good reasons some of their could some of
their complaints are good some of them
aren't and a lot of in the potato stack
world we've actually been sort of like
whatever I'm not sure what the problem
is we really steal all the time we have
multi-threaded code all the time not
every PI did a function does but it sort
of like this mantra there's that sci fi
2015 this year there was like release
the Gil everybody it really doesn't it
makes things nicer on multi-core CPUs
numpy does it numpy takes a lot of pains
actually to release the Gil when it can
sci fi does it most of the time quite
often scikit-learn now does it
I pandas is going to do it or now does
it I know there's a lot of there's some
effort involved in making it it released
the Gil when it can scythe on makes it
easy to release the Gil and number makes
it easy as well it's a very simple thing
you do have to be intentional about it
though
it doesn't just automatically release
the guilt because you do need to make
sure your code thread safe or else it's
gonna be trouble I mean there's actually
some benefit having Python not release
the Gil it makes it much easier you're
not always writing multi-threaded code
you have to be intentional about writing
multi-threaded code but when you know
you can there's many cases where you can
on the function of being called from
Python you just put no Gil equals true
notice in this example I don't have to
put no Gil equals true on all the
functions being called only on the
function I intend to call from Python so
the intermediates the gills already
released so that's already in there
a global interpreter lock those are
already happening the thread but you'd
better make sure that your code is
thread safe you know not using Global's
is usually the problem not updating any
arrays that others other threads might
be trying to update at the same time as
well so there are some caveats but
releasing the Gil and in this example
we're using the the really nice
concurrent thread pool executors from
Python 3 plug for Python 3 it's got a
lot of neat features and cool things the
thread pool executors in Python 3 and
you can see you get not the quite linear
speed-up
very very simple to release the Gil get
thread actually have calculation
functions multiple threads using number
for a subset of Python many people
didn't wait amazed that something don't
realize this but CUDA Python is a number
you can actually write code for the GPU
in open source Python it's completely
open source you can all do it you do
have to have GPU and you do have to be
willing to learn some CUDA right you'd
have to it's CUDA Python meaning that
you still have to understand code a
little bit what it means to take code
write a kernel and what that means I'm
like I'm not I'm a GPU you look in there
and you see CUDA thread blocks could a
thread could have block could have
blocked in okay and if you don't know
CUDA it's like what is all that stuff
and you have to kind of be clear about
what that is you're writing a kernel
you're writing a little function that's
gonna run a thousand virtual threads or
ten thousand virtual threads so you have
to basically know what you're gonna do
on each one of those threads and so
that's all that's happening here it's a
very simple scaling function I'm scaling
a destination and a source I can't
allocate arrays in CUDA that's one thing
that's different so there's a CUDA JIT
it's from Numa import CUDA who to dodge
it and then I have to call it
differently because I have to give the
GPU an understanding of how many threads
per block how many blocks per grid I
intend to use this on so the interface
is a little bit you know there's some
effort there but with not very much
investment and with python syntax you
can write GPU code and a lobule and
doing it to great effect here's an
example of black-scholes calculation
done on the GPU not going to go over
that detail when you can basically see
9x faster then the load than the CPU
code and about the same speed as CUDA
see so now CUDA is open to Python you
and you can just have a GP on your
machine and it's a little bit of
fearlessness and willingness to
experiment and you can do a great job
all right so we are out of time but
there's some other interesting things
could a simulator generalize you phone
call type luminary support four types
understand the buffer protocol number
annotate very good idea to understand
what's going wrong those are all there
and then list of what doesn't work
you'll from generators there but not
yield from recursion and exceptions
there's a lot there some of these things
that make Python really nice that you
have to take a subset in order to use
number but that subset is growing and
growing and for array oriented code with
arrays and scalars works really really
well and gives you a pretty good result
and I'm excited about what's coming JIT
classes that will be interesting open a
whole new world for people to create
basically a little record record arrays
and record classes that can then go all
over the place more coverage than pay
API and bug workflows and so forth thank
the number team again I was very excited
about number I'm a champion of number I
push number wherever I can but there's a
big group of people that actually make
this all work Graham Antoine sue John
Graham Oscar J thanks to all of them and
any of you that are using number and
we're giving us reports they really
build all those people are very
interested in your success and failures
so if you fail tell them and they'll
nerd swipe them and get them to work for
you so please please join us and thanks
appreciate it nice to be here